hello the internet I'm gav I'm Dan we're
the slo-mo guys and today we're in bama
we're all tired indeed we don't really
do gun videos very often on this channel
yeah ten not to last time we were here
and we had an M4 on uh fully automatic
very scary we've also been known to use
a dweebie little air pistol but today
they're massively stepping it up a notch
by approximately one knot I can't even
fit in the face yeah
destined for smart over days uh lent us
this Beefcake of a 50 cal thanks Dustin
once again it's gonna blow you away you
want me to fire it oh you're gonna be
fine yeah absolutely yeah the other one
I was I was terrified of this one's
gonna
stop my heart it's like it's going to
detach my brain stand ridiculous can I
try holding it yeah all right
[Laughter]
breathe
this is not messing around if it looks
heavy that's because it is I'm trying to
compare it to something weight-wise it's
like a TV
it is very big Telly a deadly TV that
could destroy like cars all right you
take it back terrified all right so
let's start setting up Phantoms and
getting some lovely high speed shots
yeah it's bigger than I thought it would
be
it's very big it's large it is yeah yeah
why'd you have this why yeah
to hang out with you guys
we'll come over and see
that's pretty much how that happened
thanks for having us Dustin
why am I going first look at the size of
the route look at it it's I'd be proud
of that I think
look at the size of the magazine as well
this is like twice the size of a normal
magazine I've only seen them on the
floor in in like Call of Duty and
Battlefield yeah it's huge huge and they
disappear look at the size of it next to
his nose
that's it now up
that's it
so now all you need to do is make ready
by pulling the [ __ ] handle back
releasing
and it's made ready to fire all right
gonna fire
oh
oh yes the barrel comes miles back I
tried to open my eye oh yeah yeah
and I don't want it closed for sure
so incredibly violent it's meaty isn't
it you look so profesh
I look fresh you look an operator oh
okay
open both your eyes look at your serious
face oh there we go you think is you
close your eyes because you knew you
were going to pull the trigger look you
close your eyes and my mindset was I'm
gonna open my eyes and pull the trigger
yeah let me close them it was so funny
like the air moved before the gun and it
like shook your face and then the gun
shakes you off first
incredible amounts for
not too bad
it's quite fun
I think that is tooth shattering yeah
you can see the shock wave visibly go
from the end of the weapon there
followers all the way down the gun into
me
and then I react
like a sack of milk very violent
Newton's Cradle yeah
[Music]
lovely stuff pinch pinch all right so
we've got some nice high-speed shots
there yeah lovely that's the actual
gun going off what should we shoot with
it I want to see how much water we can
kick up luckily
a pond right there how high do you think
the water splash will go I reckon 30
feet 30 feet yeah
yeah I'm gonna shoot it really wide then
leaving a lot of room in the upper frame
for uh for the Splash Zone okay
oh yes
foreign
did some extra gums come out with it
look at that one tiny bit just going
straight up that splash of water is not
messing around it's ridiculous does it
come out of frame you you panned up you
panned up with it yeah I was like nice
you got it all yeah it's kind of it's
the same color as the sky but it went
beyond the top of the tree line from
here wow how many feet is that I don't
know
and wait so it went equal to the height
of that part of the tree
that is about
25 meters up
which I think is like a mile and a half
yeah something like that
I have to say though I don't think I've
felt more badass than I did there you
caught a dragonfly you scared a
dragonfly is what you did all right
dragonfly is like someone just shot my
pond with a 50 cal I was trying to get
it on lay some eggs down there got a
fish
the dragonfly just flying away I was
wicked all right that's a very easy
target
so why don't we see if you can hone in
your aim and uh we'll revisit our candle
shooting video
you got it yeah go ahead Racket and Fire
okay safely off
you missed
no you missed
[Music]
foreign
you got it so close that the wind put
out the candle and then it re-lit itself
no yeah you are having to curve a bullet
around the earth to hit this candle yes
the distance is involved
yeah yeah all right we're gonna shoot
ground level with some debris
on the floor it's just leaves we'll see
if it kicks them up
ready yep
[Music]
yeah it's a good visualization of how
far that spreads it just looks like it
comes out because it's a baffle here a
huge battle it's like an artillery
battle like it's about like forces it
all the way back around here
it's amazing
it's like an instant Windstar yeah
we're flying now looking at that I can't
imagine what that's like for bugs
walking around
there's a question an ant
just one day looking for food in the
next larger yeah he's deaf and he's 10
feet from where he was before well Dad I
thought that was some lovely looking
footage the shock waves that come out of
that thing I've got a headache I fight
you fight it like twice yeah I fight
about 15 times I actually got headache
from filming you firing it if the
pressure wave still hit me every time it
rattles your brain it's a brain wrapper
even if you know it's gonna happen right
when it gets fired if you're not firing
it yourself you can't help but jump you
can't help it yeah yeah I agree if
you're gonna get into the stealth
industry I don't recommend this as your
weapon of choice because everyone will
look at you it's got a sling on it as
well so you can have a sling just walk
along with it hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to follow us on Twitter
or Instagram
forget Twitter I'll do Instagram this
week how about that same name same name
same name this is Destin's gun and we
use Destin's camera as well so why don't
you give some love to Destin's Channel
smarter every day I watch it all the
time and you can subscribe to us as well
if you want yeah that's fine we will see
you right back here for the next video
can I uh put this down yeah it's really
heavy yeah it's a Dallas package
don't carry that around
you wanna go get some barbecue yeah I
mean we are in Alabama my back